hey kids work back the new rock stars my
name is Sam Bosch and I'm here to break
down the mid-season finale for the flash
aka 409 don't run this all an episode in
my opinion fantastic setup for the rest
of the season I'm very excited but let's
not forget the most important part the
references the hidden gems of the show
runners and the riders left for us let's
go hunt in of course here's your spoiler
warning for the flash TV show comics
movies etc good good let's get going oh
my god there are so many holiday winks
and nods and not just two different
movies and TV shows and songs and
specials here's a quick montage go
remain one I wouldn't touch you 39 a
half football did a Rudolph just
diarrhea all over your trees committees
made my naughty
do you have ourselves a merry little
Christmas like a bowl full of jelly why
don't you come over and chill my best
huh while they were great and plentiful
let's focus on the main come booked
goodies starting with number 10 on my
list
gudren forth through the episode just a
bit to the thinker and the mechanic
planning their next move we hear the
mechanic say that the thinker will share
a birthday with a messiah but it was a
messiah we now know that this is
foreshadowing the final reveal of the
thinker body swap but also I think this
is foreshadowing the future of this
season hear me out there the thinkers
running around in a brand new body but I
don't think that this is his end goal
and one of the thinker's biggest comic
runs written by Geoff Johns the fingers
main goal is to take over the body of
the flash namely Wally West he's the
main flash at this time in the comics
the fastest mind alive I guess and since
we're gonna need some plot for the back
half of this season maybe this spring
line here then this really wasn't born
until spring would be referring to the
thinker gaming Barry's mind later this
season maybe who knows but probably but
who knows but that's probably what's
gonna happen well we do know is that the
thinker is currently in control of
Dominic Lance's body aka brainstorm I'll
be honest my least favorite name but hey
we're working with it now this is our
number 9 on the list now there are a few
brain storms in the comics but their
powers are basically the same one being
Dominic Lance and the other being axel
storm who is this classy number for a
hat oh boy this is written a long time
ago it's great now usually none of them
have telepathy but they have some sort
of mental ability whether it be mind
control and illusion casting you know
the fun ones this actually is a pretty
fun twist for the show because not only
does Dominic have the smartest brain
alive now thanks to the thing correctly
he also still has
left the likely meaning and he can pull
as much knowledge as he'd like from the
people around him making him far more
threatening cool also I'd like to point
out that in the comic books
Lance also has this floating apparatus
that he stands on maybe we'll see
brainstorms floating platform in the
future since he's not gonna probably use
that chair anymore I'm a fan of that
chair which I'm gonna talk about in a
little bit stay tuned and moving on to
number eight we get an awesome nod to
another extremely popular DC Universe
out there in the multiverse that also
confirms a specific storyline has
happened oh my god I'm just so excited
take a look at this clip a gulag class
mekin I forged in the unholy blood fires
of earth 22 by none other than us 2.0
BAM now we know that Wells 2.0 is from
earth 22 which they mentioned in this
episode which is also in the multiverse
guide designated as the Kingdom Come
universe the future earth we're young
and old heroes are at odds with one
another that's all I say don't get into
spoilers based on how Wells to point O
has described his earth it doesn't quite
line up with earth 22 in the comics but
the weapon that Cisco got [ __ ] for
christmas sounds an awful lot like the
famous prison from Kingdom Come a gulag
class neck knife war gulag being the red
flag because comic fans should know that
the gulag was the name of the prison of
Superman built on earth 22 for young
heroes and weren't staying in line it's
pretty cool if you ask me maybe all our
old heroes live on that earth altogether
not on a weird separate Earth's like
Earth 38 we're super ellipse and maybe
possibly hopefully next up number 7 goes
to Cisco getting the shock of a lifetime
Sarika me one little clip for two
reasons since this could actually be a
nod to two different nerdy properties
I'll let you pick which one you prefer
number one Sark is one of the main
antagonists from the original Tron movie
who was killed off this works in Cisco
shocked himself on a motherboard or cue
this could be a nod to Julian Sark David
Anders alias character the TV show alias
some of that you're all babies when that
was on so kind of fun not cuz he's on
iZombie on the same network CW mmm-hmm
maybe this one's a bit of a stretch but
it was pretty obvious that Cisco was
probably a alias fan I mean look at him
of course he was and moving on to number
6 let's talk about this awesome Superman
40 psi of inhalation anesthetic that'll
keep them out but not for long
BAM I mean this is also not to the
american dad a large - Superman - I'm
doing what has to be done here up first
the gas son of a [ __ ] Superman to me
which I love American debt if you guys
love them to tweet me about your
thoughts cuz I'm it's that show or no if
it's on right now I'm gonna be honest if
you guys are missing it I'm referring to
when Superman tricks his enemies in this
case Zod and - getting exposed to a
harmful agent to gain the upper hand
instead of exposing Zod to red sunlight
I'm Annette gets exposed to anesthesia
clever girl that Caitlin over there and
now all we need is a recreation of the
cellphone s and I'll be very happy that
will probably happen on Supergirl in
season 10 well we might have to wait to
get that special little moment we did
get one of my favorite powers of the
flash in this episode five to be exact
on my list
[Music]
I am the impossible most famous moment
of this happening in the comics is
during identity crisis with Wally he
makes himself invisible with Kyle right
here making himself invisible as well
once again I know you guys are gonna
point out that the writers are taking
Wally West storylines or plot points or
abilities and giving them to Barry I'm
just happy we're getting it at all guys
I mean come on be happy with what you
get sometimes speaking of copy and
pasting attributes let's talk about
number four in the list when we got the
confirmation in this episode but the
writers of the flash have actually given
us a live-action Mobius chair we've all
been noticing the similarities to the
new gods tech but now has been confirmed
with this scene
and the one thing we've been missing for
the thinker's share to be identical to
the Mobius chair is teleportation and we
got it in this episode oh my goodness
this show is going crazy if you guys
missed it in previous episodes of my
breakdowns the Mobius chair is a tool
from the New Gods that allows the person
sitting in it to travel through time
teleport have untold knowledge it's
pretty cool also I love the scene when
we got to see the fight between the
chair the thinker and the flash the CGI
wasn't incredible I'll be honest this
stuff pretty cool also I do love that
this chair borrowed something from
Marvel Comics I mean come on we've had
robotic arms in many different forms in
comics but this definitely feels like a
Doc Ock doesn't it or maybe brainiacs
arms fun thing those arms got using it
pretty cool but also very scary way
during our number-3 moment on my list
I'm gonna think you're working together
always a pleasure doing business with
another savvy woman I mentioned this in
past videos but this season is based on
Geoff Johns flash run which dealt with
AMA net and the thinker facing off it is
pretty cool to see them working together
I'll be honest but this feels like it's
leading to them possibly turning on each
other in the future I'm feeling that all
right you guys let me know down below
but this moves us to number 2 of the
list the actual scary clip
oh wow I feel bad for job that's no fun
that's no fun at all I think I got an
idea what happened to the weeper
remember him thinker got him - maybe
he's fine
I don't know but anyways like I
mentioned before the thinker has swapped
minds in the comics specifically with
the flash this doesn't get me thinking
could the thinker possibly swap bodies
with more than one person more than just
brainstorm and Barry would you like it
to be let me know down below I'm gonna
be honest I'm most excited to see how
this show is going to handle the framing
of Barry Allen clever clever way to take
Barry out of the picture mister thing
yeah yeah be a smart one don't you this
is our number one slot of course it
burns it but also I'm feeling like this
is leading to one of the biggest flash
storylines of all time the one that
flash fans have been begging for the
trial of the flash in this case Barry is
framed for the murder of the thinker
which is pretty dang clever but in the
comics Barry actually accidentally
killed reverse-flash
eobard thawne snapped his neck who seen
that before one interesting connection
that I think I should point out to the
original story and this is that in the
clip for the next episode we're getting
in January Barry has the same lawyer as
he does in the comics Cecille which
makes sense because that's one of her
biggest stories in the comics so this is
eventually going to lead to the trial of
the flash and her representing Barry
as for what enlightenment might be my
guess is that the writers might be
pulling from the Justice League God and
monsters animated movie in that
storyline light spoilers the main
villain wants to connect all mines on
the planet which in this case wouldn't
really bring about world peace but would
allow the think you're more brain space
hmm are you guys thoughts on the
thinker's plan let me know your theories
down below but here we go quick
honourable mention time my favorite
number one I love that iris is salty
about Felicity stealing her thunder and
getting married - I love that she's
finally iris west-allen like in the
newspaper Barry might disappear again
number three when ralph refers to the
satellite as sally this could actually
be a nod to the song sally the satellite
maybe that's a stretch I'm gonna go with
yes
number four the killer frost iced mocha
is fun and I know she's a good guy now
but she did tried to kill people in the
past right I'm just saying the city was
quick to forget about that number five
when ralph decorated joe's house for
christmas he hung
a booby shirt on a chair still
symbolizing that he's a slimeball but we
love him and finally number six did
anyone get some get out vibes with the
whole mind swapping storyline with
Dominic old or dying white guy takes
over the body of a young black man a
little bit the internet point of this
out and now I can't not see it I mean
who doesn't let me get out I get it but
still anyways guys that's it from me I
hope you enjoyed this video happy
holidays I hope you guys give this video
like subscribe to new rock stars for
more videos and check out all of our
other ones like need to know how I'm on
that show it's a fun one follow me on
twitter at sam bachelor to talk more
about the flash and other nerdy things
great a holiday break if you've got that
I'll see you guys next time bye bye